you just heard Tom Bossert earlier in
the show calling for a denuclearized
North Korea we've also heard from
Senator Lindsey Graham tweeting this
weekend giving the leader of North Korea
the ability to strike the United States
with a nuclear-tipped ICBM is simply
unacceptable now you're on record saying
we have to accept North Korea as a
nuclear State what would your response
be to Tom Bossert and to a Lindsey
Graham well saying it's not acceptable
as a yeah ideally I'd love a
denuclearized North Korea but as I
learned when I went there and I had some
pretty intense dialogue with them that
is a non-starter with them that is their
ticket to survival and I say anyway
they're going to give it up so I think
our process our thought process here
ought to be on accepting it and trying
to cap it or control it but I think a
dude a DD burglarize North Korea I'd
love to see it but I don't think that's
in the cards